you grace grace now all you'd better
kneel every time I fart and if you fall
don't scream you don't want that to be
the last thing she remembers most men
[ __ ] like dogs done your [ __ ] shouldn't
go near Jesus slick as a baby seal and
then you go inside but slowly don't jam
it in like you're spearing a pig come on
you'd I have to tell you about her
Ashida
nice and soft down below oh she was no
ordinary Beast that is the man whatever
I know you never [ __ ] her back today I
ask my people to fight with the crows is
the day my people cut my guts from my
belly and make me eat them dude get down
on your knees and suck either the others
and let's talk you vouch for this man
total it's prettier than both my
daughters no God I know I saw your
pecker what kind of God would have a
Becca that small I haven't to go sell
goats look stronger than any of that
grape water you southern twice like
sucking on no thanks so does something
delicious but I can never sleep the
night before a bottle what do you do all
night think and walk and tell them far
enough away from camps that no one can
hear me [ __ ] my guts out happy
[ __ ] closest Castle to hardhome is
eastwatch-by-the-sea and that's where
I'll go looks like we're the Knights
which now
you're a lucky man
down south the air smells like the big
[ __ ]
you've never been down south I've been
to Winterfell that's the north how'd you
get your balls for freezing off got to
keep moving that's the secret
walking's good Fighting's better [ __ ]
stressed it's not a living woman with an
older male we have to make do with what
we've got
I wanna suck my dick is that it dick
talk Oh dick I like it
Brienne of Tarth you know her your was
Brienne of [ __ ] Tarth well what with
her yet I see the way she looks at me
I'll just live in you and she wants to
carve you up and into your liver you do
know her we've met
how did a mad [ __ ] like you live this
long I'm gonna kill deep
I killed the Giant when I was 10 then I
climbed her right into bed with his wife
you know what you did suckle meditate
for three months that's how I got so
strong Giants milk women can't be
Knights why not
tradition folk tradition I'm no king but
if over I denied you 10 times over
vomiting is not celebrated as it is
most people get bloody murdered they
stay that way
not this one here north of the wall and
him back here again
he keeps firing he climbed on the
[ __ ] dragon and folks I'm not afraid
of what maybe you should be you're not
gonna ride the dragon south ray girl
needs to heal he doesn't need me wearing
him down you wear as much as two fleas
[ __ ] you've got the North in you the
real North